there's only two kinds of straight
people in this world
the ones that hate you to your face and
the ones that hate you behind your back
for me the title queer spoke means queer
as people
there's nothing in this we haven't seen
uh two straight people
do actually that's not true there is
him in your office it was the best thing
to come across my desk in a long time
the honest non-comical non-stereotypical
portrayal of gay people
that's the thing that's most
groundbreaking about it i mean you don't
see
a film or television depictions of gay
men where where there's not at
their core some sort of horrendous
self-hatred and that's
revolutionary it takes more courage to
wear a dress for an hour than it does to
wear a suit for a lifetime
there's just no denying the impact
that showing people the truth
can have because it allows people to
understand themselves
and when you understand yourself you can
understand the people around you
where you're headed everything's special
[Music]
i can change that my homosexuality's
just been dealt with in a comedic
sense a half hour sitcoms it's like
women and minorities and homosexualities
right they're all funny
but nobody deals with them seriously i
think it was because i
smothered him you smother a pork chop
not a son people
are what they are it is very provocative
it is very uh graphic but it's real
i mean it it it's not done just to
tantalize the audience
it's done because that's what goes on
i'm sure there'll be people
furious i'm sure there'll be people
turning off their tvs but i do think if
people will
if they'll sit there if they'll sit
through their discomfort if they'll sit
through
those moments and they're like wow i've
never never seen anything like that
before
that they will come to understand
something better about themselves
when you tell a specific story as
honestly as you can it becomes universal
we've gotten some wonderful letters um
kids who
didn't have the nerve to come out and
have
um have their parents sit and watch it
with them
and that's how they tell them we've had
some really sad ones of people who were
going to end their life
and they saw this show and it changed
their life
you